this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular celebrities pop in to have a
drink
sometimes they share stories and even
secrets because as we all know what the
bartender ears is confidential isn't it
so I'm sitting there telling bath when
in what's one of them as famous
customers Mario it comes in sits down or
does a ragout of sunshine daiquiri only
he didn't it didn't look himself who
fade down the dumps so asked him I'll
sit his to end once what's the long face
he says trouble with the missus also PJ
says no Donkey Kong years of age
so while says to tell late only he says
well it's some you know cleaning the
pipes if you know the lane I said no no
I don't know it's me I says no trouble
in the bedroom that says your problem
plumbing in the bedroom you have a water
bed or something he says sex I'm talking
about sex I got eyes all the nose so you
know I'll ask him I'll say or you go
problem getting up you know a what up he
says I so you know nail and the hammer
brothers goes huh so you know hit the
warp zone it goes a and I say Darby
bastard I'm talking about direction it
goes oh no no no no I gotta got special
a fungus for that you know eat it you
grow like ten times your size so you
know it's no problem with that yeah do
that we decide to lay all the innuendos
you know and just they want coming
across and Zuma the childish so ask him
uh says well what's the problem veins as
I told you the missus I'm like oh yeah
yeah so awesome listening as Elmo get
more tip mi aces no no you're not
he's a sly one they go
and ulcers all right what's wrong with
her then he says ma'am she's just into
really really weird stuff I go oh you
like midgets or something he goes no no
girl half a kingdom is mushroom midgets
in it she doesn't want any of that I
mean like really really out there stuff
what schiessen something he goes no
goddess pleaded disgusting I'll say like
what then and he says well you know like
chains and collars and whips dressing up
like dragons I go all your wait a minute
wait a minute
dressing up like dragons well it's kind
of a long story he says but a bottom
line you know she's been kidnapped like
umpteen for jillion times and after a
while she began to enjoy it you know
like really get into it al says what do
you mean he says what do I mean
I mean Super Mario Brothers Stockholm
Syndrome that's what I made that first
it starts off very simple you know like
saying mean things fake nastily like
your kingdom is mine no one can hear you
scream
Mario's never gonna save you which is
odd seeing how freakin Mario I mean Who
am I save enough from that meself
they told me he started is it when she
start requesting the cage I mean I'm
into all sorts of weird stuff he says
but this is just flat-out pasta module
so she wants to be trussed up in a cage
while our dress up like a dragon a truck
that's borderline bestiality and then
she wasn't me to breathe fire you
serious I mean those flowers are fallen
dandy but do you know how much halitosis
one kids or hopin Mamma Mia he says I
have to go through 15,000 packs of
mylanta so my throat doesn't feel hotter
than a Mexican's anus but also still
more so well it seems like you're in a
bit of a Barney goes what's a Barney
say you know Molly Rubble Molly trouble
trouble trouble it's big trouble he says
once you say big trouble us I don't feel
it's a cockney thing it's just our talk
you know sure you say stupid things all
the time he says no no I never say
stupid things like oh yeah it's the
Italian plumber imagine never says
anything stupid so he gets a bit angry I
apologize I say you know just sometimes
I rap along you know count like those
pipe lasers you know and the levels he's
bending they just go round and round and
all that stuff so well was I oh yeah his
wife's that kinky slut so anyway this
all comes to a head after a particularly
long bout of erotic Italian mushroom
lovemaking so he's got the cage he's got
the chains even got all his servants
toad to dress up like Bowser form so he
didn't have to cause toad is a small
bloke so this was starting to look like
a David Lynch doctor my bro experiment
but when she want him to go through the
eight levels of Louisville soaked
dungeons of welding fire chains that's
when he drew the line and drew it he did
drew it all the way to the pixel palace
she's probably still up there right now
waiting for something savor let the
little peach roll he says if actually
might be give Bowser a call have him
come over to see her trussed up in a
cage with a smaller version of him
standing guard I like then to figure
that one out
so asked him I said well what are you
gonna do I says I'm gonna have five more
ragout daiquiris I'm just gonna let
nature take its course the artist drinks
walked out the last I have us often
hopefully you see a lot of strange
things at the pixel Palace so you'll all
strange things as a bartender so I'll
see a lot of strange things as a
bartender and the pixel palace that
ain't no line sweat Oh